Tăng này với đa số phíau tăng thành có hội đã thương qua sự an lột nhà giáo một trình chính xách nổi bật của lột.
Là quy định lần của nhà giáo được sếp cao nhất trong hệ thống thang bật lương khán chính xự nghiệp.
Pua lần nhà giáo còn được hưởng phụ cấp yêu đã như và phụ cấp khác.
Tuyet theo, phụ cấp khác với phát theo vùng.
Chào mừng sống, mừng sống.
nhà giáo cấp học bấm nôn nhà giáo công tác ở vùng lần bà rất tâm một số, mừng mừng mừng mừng mừng mừng hơi đau.
Vùng đặc biệt khó khăn và nhà giáo ở một số ngành ngay đặt thù được hưởng lương và phụ cấp cao hơn sau với nhà giáo làm việc trong được kìm mình thường.
Lột nhà giáo cú không cấm việc của dậy thêm học thêm.
Chỉ quy định nhà giáo không được em bột người học thăm sau thêm, giới mọi hình thức,
nhằm hạn chế khóc phục tình trạng học thêm, dậy thêm tràn lan và sự lợi.
Về thêm quyền tiền dục, lột giáo ngành giáo giúp quyền chủ động trong tiền dục xử dụng nhà giáo.